Wow, you're still here.
That is some perseverance.
I'm proud of you.
Let's keep going.
I'm happy to report this is an easy one.
Identity as a service.
What does that mean?
It means we can do any of the stuff that we have already talked about around identity
and access management, except that we can do it in the cloud.
That's identity as a service.
There's a little more to it than they need to know.
Here's the table.
There are a number of different identities that we can use in identity as a service.
So let's go through each of these and I'll provide you a nice simple definition of each
one.
Let's start with cloud identity.
The idea of a cloud identity is that the identity, your information, your credential
information is entirely stored in the cloud and you authenticate in the cloud because
everything is stored in the cloud.
That's cloud identity.
Sync identity is where you have an identity in your local corporate store on premise and
you have an identity in the cloud and sync means that they are connected and a change to
one is synchronized to the other, a change to this one is synchronized to the other one.
So sync identities, they're synchronized.
And the authentication can occur either on premise or in the cloud.
Federated identity is where you use federated access.
This whole process that we've already talked through about having three entities, the identity
provider, the relying party, the service provider, and the user or the principal.
And where the actual identity provider is located whether it's on premise or in the cloud
doesn't matter.
Federated identity is just this concept of using federated access.
And the last one is known as a linked identity.
This is where you still have two separate identities, one on premise and one in the cloud.
But the key difference between linked identity and synced identity, in sync, there was if
a change was made to one, it was synchronized to the other.
In linked, there's a connection to say that these are both accounts that belong to the
same user, but an update to one does not synchronize automatically, update the other.
And so in linked identity, if you change this account in the cloud, it doesn't automatically
update this local account and vice versa.
So those are the major types of accounts that we can use in the cloud.
And the final piece slide here is just related to what are all the services that we can have
in identity as a service.
And like I said, it's anything that you can do on premise, you can do provisioning,
you can do access management, you can do single sign-on, you can do multi-factor, all
of this stuff, you can do it in the cloud.